and then here's the crazy part guys if
you get close and you cast lumos lumos
look at that
look at that she moves behind the tent
how many of you guys
have found this secret right here
how many of you have found this one this
is really cool so look at that nothing
when you do revelio but if you look at
your map look at that look at that mini
map
it looks like there should be something
behind there took you all gave to find I
know look at that man just hidden in
plain sight
okay and I think we can do the next part
too I don't think there's any uh
there's not an Aloha more or anything
this is such a cool room right here
let's see where is the
yeah right over here at the beginning
so here's the field guide page for it
werewolf Saga tapestries this set of
tapestries tells the tragic tale of a
witch bitten by a werewolf she chose to
flee from her home to protect her infant
daughter and husband rumor has it that
her daughter fell asleep to the howl of
a wolf for years thereafter
now you might think that's where the
secret ends
but remember it said it tells the story
so if you walk around here and just get
a good look at all these pictures here
so here you have the mom and the
daughter right there
and then you have them here with kind of
a traveling party
same thing looks like they're out on a a
hunt
[Music]
and then they encounter a werewolf
the father you can see holding the baby
trying to protect the baby and the wife
she's standing behind him right here
there's the werewolf
and then right here
they show her with the baby they show
the family and what is that one is that
one like
oh maybe this is a nurse or something
you think
maybe maybe she was bitten between this
one and this one and we don't see it
and then right here
it looks like he has just gotten some
bad news
and then here's the crazy part guys if
you get close and you cast lumos lumos
look at that
look at that she moves behind the tent
and she just looks
very distraught at this moment
so we go to the next one here
look at her look at that now she's
crying
oh that one's crazy
then it looks like they're hunting her
but now she's she's running away
is what I get from it that's my
interpretation of it then we go back to
this one lumos
and again
it looks like they're hunting her at
this point she's running away
let me go right here
and now she's watching them as they're
kind of traveling back home
my interpretation of the story and then
probably the saddest one of all
or transformation is now complete into
the werewolf and you got to think this
was probably long before the wolf Spain
potion was a thing
it was way more manageable once
Lupine you know in Harry Potter's day
when Lupine was a werewolf way more
manageable
oh
so sad right